thank you for joining us at the fifth
annual clinical diagnostics and research
online conference Life Technologies
brand of thermo fisher's a proud sponsor
of today's webinar on sequencing gene
fusions my name is Rina coroner Aetna
and I'm a marketing manager at life
technologies and will be your moderator
for today's presentation I'm proud to
introduce Kelly Bramblett who is our
first speaker in today's presentation
miss Bramlett leads the RNA sequencing
applications team at life sciences
solutions prior to joining thermo fisher
scientific miss Bramlett was a drug
development scientist at eli lilly and
company where she led a team of
scientists specializing in gene
regulation and nuclear receptor biology
to identify novel drug targets i'm also
proud to introduce jeffrey shagmon who
will be our second speaker in today's
presentation jeffrey segment is a staff
scientist in the aren't RNA sequencing
applications team at life sciences
solutions thermo fisher scientific he
specializes in the development and
implementation of analytical methods for
NGS and gene expression analysis Kelly
and Jeffrey will be speaking to today
two will be speaking today on
multiplexed gene multiplex fusion gene
detection using next-generation
sequencing also at the end of the
presentation I will be facilitating QA
so please feel free to submit questions
during the presentation on your screen
and now I would like to turn it over to
Kelly and Geoffrey for their
presentation
hello everyone it's morning in Texas
which is where I am so i'm going to say
good morning and thank you for devoting
a little bit of time today to learn
about a new technology we have to detect
fusion genes and a highly multiplexed
fashion using next-generation sequencing
today I'm just going to talk a little
bit about some of the challenges with
fusion and transcript or fusion gene
analysis currently then I'm going to
tell you about the iron amp will seek
RNA technology that is a new technology
recently introduced I'm a little bit
about RNA isolation from particularly
difficult sample types and then really
kind of wrap these two these discussions
together in a section on using the Ayia
Napa seek RNA technology to detect on
fusion genes in a multiplexed fashion
then just going to take over and talk
about specific design of assays to
detect fusion genes and also some of the
analysis capabilities we have as Rana
pointed out please as you have questions
throughout the presentation and capture
them and will address those at the end
and a Q&A section so as many of you on
the phone are much more aware than than
myself I'm sure chromosomal
translocations are common in cancer and
these are rearrangements of the
chromosome that often result in a novel
gene that is a result of a fusion of two
different genes so we call these fusion
genes
and very often they may produce
oncogenic proteins that drive disease
progression these types of events are
observed in many types of disease
including hematological diseases
prostate cancer I'm sarcomas and lung
some of the gene families most well
understood and involved in these
different types of diseases are shown on
this slide on vc are able many many
people are well aware of in human to
logical cancers also email for alch
fusions or really any fusion without has
been an area of interest lately for lung
as we think about fusions and how they
occur fusion genes and how they occur
and and what they're driving you often
find partners that are involved in
multiple isoforms of the fusion fusion
gene event in various types of cancer so
we want we would like to be able to
detect not only the fusion genes that
are most prevalent but really any events
multiple events that might happen
between the driver fusion gene for lung
this might be out for instance these
fusion genes have been used as
indicators of not only cancer type but
progression and perhaps for drug targets
and detection methods are challenging
though currently I'm really the the gold
standard for translocation or fusion
gene detection is looking at the DNA
level using fluorescent in situ
hybridization or fish these are DNA
probes that are either break apart
probes or break away pro
or you may have probes to each member of
the fusion gene with fluorescence that
you need to see in close proximity to
each other this technology works well
but it is somewhat subjective and
requires expert mr. pathologists to
review each slide and usually multiple
pathologists to review each slide also
you can really only look at one or two
fusion events at a time due to probes
and you know just the procedure of of
exposing a slide or a patient sample to
these pros immunohistochemistry is also
used to look at the expression of some
fusion genes again labor-intensive and
can really only look at a few genes at a
time another method that's becoming more
utilized is Archie rt-pcr and these can
be very specific tests for a specific
fusion gene event can be multiplexed a
little bit but in order to increase the
plexi or or test for multiple fusions at
once you really start needing more and
more sample which often times is a
problem fusion genes can also be the
identified via RNA sequencing so deep
RNA sequencing this however is a very
time-consuming and labor-intensive
technology that really requires expert
bioinformatics analysis that not every
lab has and certainly many clinical labs
don't have so there are some challenges
with detecting on fusion genes in the
field currently
so if we start thinking about what what
we need to study fusion transcripts or
fusion genes what what would be nice we
would like to be able to look at
multiple fusion simultaneously I'm tens
to hundreds perhaps we would like to be
able to do this from love sample inputs
so that a fine needle aspirate or an
ffpe block or a biopsy sample would be
enough to detect multiple fusions at
once and then we would like you know
comparable or better accuracy than fish
and it would be nice if it was easier to
perform than fish a fast time to results
and and potentially a lower cost because
you would look at all fusion
simultaneously to assay them
individually now starts incurring quite
a bit of cost so we'd like to be able to
address all of these key factors so in
comes a new technology I am placing RNA
this is a method to sequence RNA in a
targeted fashion so instead of creating
a library of all the RNA in a tissue or
sample on this technology allows you to
specifically look at an individual RNAs
that are of most interest to you to you
so it's very highly multiplex targeted
RNA sequencing we can look at gene
expression measurements and and get
nucleotide resolution for those specific
amplicons that that we're going to use
during the Heian applic technology we
can look at from 12 to 12 hundred genes
at once and importantly you only need
about ten nanograms of
compromised RNA or RNA from preserved
tissue such as formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissues denoted here
and further in this presentation is ffpe
we would also like to be able to barcode
multiple libraries in sequence them all
at once further driving down costs and
maximizing time and turnaround time
additionally we would really like it
easy and simple data readout that didn't
need you know a large group of
specialists or bioinformatics and
personnel to interpret so we feel that
we've accomplished this with iron
ampliphi targeted RNA sequencing what
this is is basically gene specific pcr
in a multiplex fashion that we then
sequenced so we sequence pcr-amplified
and the way i like to think about it and
describe it is shown here on the slide
many of us are familiar with taqman or
quantitative rt-pcr and the way that
that it works you have a gene-specific
forward primer and reverse primer with a
gene-specific probe that sits down on
the amplicon that's generated by your
forward and reverse primers the
abundance of the gene is then measured
by reading the fluorescent signal that
you get from from the probe on the
taqman probe that's shown at the top of
the slide at the bottom of the slide
we're showing the correlation with the
taqman technology and I an embassy car
na similarly we have gene-specific
probes forward sorry primers forward and
reverse primers
importantly we can put up to 2,400
primers or 1200 assays in one
amplification reaction and instead of
needing gene-specific probes and
fluorescent signals to read the
abundance of each of the genes
interrogated we simply amplify the
specific genes and then add adapters
that are specific to Ion Torrent
sequencing platform so we actually
sequence through the pcr-amplified that
are gene-specific and we read the actual
sequence the amount of sequencing reads
that map to each of your gene-specific
amplicons correlates to the expression
level of the gene interrogated so it's a
very creative way to utilize
next-generation sequencing to
specifically look at up to 1,200 genes
there are the most interest to you with
very low input of RNA this is what the
workflow looks like again you only need
ten nanograms of FFP and that can be
highly degraded ffff PE RNA so this is
an important factor that we actually
developed into this technology we wanted
the I Annapolis ich RNA sequencing
capability to be compatible with ffpe
RNA or other compromised RNA so we've
designed assays to be fairly short so
that the amplicon generated has a high
chance of being available and highly
degraded and compromised ffpe RNA so
looking at the workflow on the left hand
side in pictorial representation on the
right hand side in
words we start with your total RNA and
have a reverse transcription step that
is randomly reverse transcribed your see
DNA or RNA into cdna the cdna is then
subjected to a gene-specific
amplification again up to 1,200 targets
in one amplification reaction we then go
through a digestion that removes the
primers so that you don't waste
sequencing space sequencing through the
known sequence and we add on then
through a ligation Ion Torrent specific
adaptor sequences these can either be
playing aion adaptor sequences or they
can be bar-coded we always utilize far
coded adaptors and that allows you to
I'm just add a molecular barcode
identifier to each library in this way
you can multiplex or pool multiple
libraries together for template prep and
sequencing so that you really maximize
your sequencing space and then you you
create at the end a sequence ready
targeted RNA derived library the whole
workflow takes about 5 hours I'm very
general molecular biology techniques
I'll be based and requiring no specific
instrumentation that a molecular biology
laboratory capable laboratory would have
so as I said we can multiplex up to
1,200 genes in one amplification
reaction and and that's what I'm showing
here the eye on an plastic RNA
technology is shown on the y-axis here
and we're comparing that to tak man so
that's taqman data is represented on the
x-axis here and importantly the about
1000 gene expression assays shown here
were accomplished in one multiplex pcr
amplification frien appli seek and
protect men they were all done
individually and 384-well plate format
requiring much more input RNA so what
these dots represent is the expression
level of each gene that is interrogated
in this panel as determined by taqman
using fluorescence to to estimate the
expression level of each gene on the
x-axis or on the y-axis using sequencing
reads you estimate the expression level
of each gene as you can see here the
data you get out is very comparable so
the sequencing technology data is very
comparable to quantitative PCR data in
this case we're looking at expression of
these 1,000 genes in the highly acid and
well-understood control rnas of human
brain reference which is abbreviated
here hvr and the universal human
reference RNA which is abbreviated here
uhr and we're looking at full changes of
the genes between those two RNAs this is
really just to mimic a type of
experiment
that may be run either in a laboratory
or or a translational research or
clinical setting where you would have a
maybe a control sample and your sample
of interest and you're looking at the
difference between these genes and
expression levels between your two RNAs
so hopefully I've convinced you that
this new technique is is exciting and a
great way to look specifically at the
RNA expression that might be of most
interest to you in your studies one very
exciting thing that you can do with this
technology is go to amplify calm and
build your own gene expression panel so
if you have a list of between twelve and
twelve hundred genes that are
interesting on to the biology or the
disease that you're most interested in
go to NYC calm and and build your own
panel and you basically login and submit
your gene list and very quickly you get
an email back saying your panel is ready
and you can go look at it and review
your panel to make sure that it's going
to meet your needs before you order it
we expect you to get your your specific
panel in about ten days and the gene
expression panel would be utilized with
the eye on RNA am plac'd library kits on
the next few slides I'll just give you
some screenshots of what it looks like
at amplify calm when you go in you can
start a new design and you select RNA
focus design as seen on the left hand
side of your screen here and
automatically it will select human for
you right now there are only human
designs available and am placing calm
and then you get a screen that says add
your
genes of interest you can either do that
individually and in the dialog box shown
here or you can upload a file you then
hit submit and within about I would say
five to ten minutes you get an email
back saying you have a neat design ready
at Aunt Lucy calm um when you go to your
amplify calm account and review review
your design you're able to look
specifically at the genes that that the
designs that have been suggested for you
it's hard to see details from the screen
so I have a little bit of automation
that will allow us to look specifically
at some of these sections your designs
come back and our sign to various
sections on this yellow one at the top
says needs attention and what that might
be I've blown it up a little bit in the
screen here is um maybe letting you know
that you've selected a gene that is very
highly expressed sometimes people are
used to using highly expressed
housekeeping genes for normalization of
data if you're using quantitative PCR
methods that's really a recommendation
we have different recommendations for
this RNA am plac'd technology we
normalize the data only by the total
number of reads to a library so you
don't have to use an endogenous gene
normalizer to get meaningful expression
results out of your sequencing data so
we don't recommend including genes like
gap TH or beta-actin or 18s that you
might have used in the past with other
technologies that is mostly because
they're so highly expressed they soak up
a lot of sequencing reads and may
actually decrease the sensitivity of
your your design to the genes that
you're
just interested in so I'm what we what
we have is a little dialog box that pops
up and says this gene you've selected is
highly expressed and may interfere with
your panel we have some alternative
suggestions for you so that's something
that might pop up in a needs attention
section of your design in the green
section are things that are designed and
you can select one of your genes and
expand the information by toggling on
the carrot next to a specific gene and
it will give you information about all
the transcripts that are expected to be
detected by the assay that is presented
to you so this may be useful information
for you you can also link out to these
through a UCSC browser that browser and
visualize the different transcripts
assigned to a gene and where our primers
will sit down and just make sure they're
going to work for you before you order
anything um after you order and get your
custom panel run your reactions make a
library sequence you then are able to
analyze your data through a simple
plug-in on the torrent sweet cerbone so
this will happen basically right on in
the sequencing instrument and the
computer that runs the instrument it's
called a coverage analysis plugin and it
gives you some nice high-level
information about your run the number of
mapped reads as shown here in the middle
of this report and the percent of reads
that were on target so we generally see
very high percentage of our reads more
than ninety percent that are on target
and meaning they the sequencing read
maps to one of the amplicons in your
panel we also have some metrics down
here about the number of amplicons in
your
panel and how many of the of the genes
or amplicons in your panel are detected
at one read ten reads up to a hundred
thousand reads so what this what this
kind of gives you a quick snapshot of is
the bearing expression level of the RNAs
in your sample that you interrogated
with your panel so many of us are used
to thinking about DNA where you have
expected numbers of genes at the DNA
level and you expect two copies in RNA
because of the the nature of RNA you may
have vastly different numbers of RNA
transcripts present for a specific gene
so what we target here with RNA am
plac'd is being able to detect genes
that are present very low levels in the
same amplification reaction as genes
that are present at tends to 100,000
times higher levels than the most lilly
expressed gene in your in your RNA so we
can cover about five logs of dynamic
range with this technology which really
allows you to focus all your sequencing
effort on and throughput on the genes
that are of most interest to you
importantly the coverage analysis plugin
also allows you to export the number of
reads that are assigned to each amplicon
or each design in your panel and this
can be imported into Excel or some other
and
this package or statistical package that
you may use so that you can compare on
libraries or look in more detail at the
at the m sequencing results again we
just use simple reads per million
normalization or or really normalized by
the total number of reads to each
library so it's a very simple
normalization that you need here so
hopefully I've introduced an interesting
new technology to you and if you start
thinking we've been talking about this
in terms of gene expression and looking
at up to 1,200 different genes at the
same time so if we go back to our
initial discussion about fusion gene
detection you can start thinking about
unique ways to use this new technology
perhaps to interrogate multiple gene
fusions at once so what we'd really like
to do is look at multiple fusion events
from one very small sample whether it's
a blood sample cells from a biopsy or a
curl from an ffpe block very little
nucleic acid amount that we would like
to interrogate all of the fusions that
might be of interest to your disease
state at once and again we'd like it to
be competitive and an offer advantages
over the gold standard of fish so um if
you combine the RNA am placing
technology I've just talked about with
some unique RNA purification
capabilities that ambien has just been a
real champion up throughout
throughout the existence of the company
we can we can really start building a
sample to sequencing solution here so an
ambien we have a lot of expertise and
history and isolating RNA from all sorts
of tissues of course you always want to
use the highest quality RNA you can to
measure gene expression or any type of
test you would want to do for RNA
however we know that often times you
don't have pristine RNA these are real
world samples very often patient tissues
and so importantly ampliphi car na works
with even degraded on it as I mentioned
before and an example of what degraded
RNA might look like as shown here on the
right these are representative of a
bioanalyzer trace normally if if your
RNA is very intact you would see
something like the top profile which has
three clear Peaks on it but really we
focus on the larger peaks to the kind of
middle of this profile those represent
18s and 28s ribosomal RNA total RNA is
has a large content of ribosomal RNA
about eighty percent of total RNA can
come from ribosomal RNA species and
that's what's shown at the top on
profile here a common RNA profile that
you would get from a tissue that you
then tried to extract RNA from this is
shown here in the middle and we would
call that partially degraded so you can
still visualize the 18s and 28s piece
you see that the 18s peak now has become
larger than the 28s peak that's because
those larger 28 as ribosomal are
a species have been fragmented and
that's what's contributing to the spiky
looking profile to the left of the
ribosomal peaks on the last lower
profile here this is highly degraded RNA
this would be what you would see if you
isolated RNA from an ffpe type of sample
or sometimes just from a sample that
took too long to get into a preserving
buffer or sat at room temperature for
too long RNA is very labile and so it's
a grapes rather quickly if you don't
protect it well so this strongly
degraded RNA you can see no more clear
ribosomal RNA Peaks from 18 s 4 28 s but
this type of RNA still works in the RNA
ampliphi technology again because the
acid designs are optimized for
fragmented and degraded RNA so that's
one really great thing about ampliphi
RNA as you know ffpe is is of interest
for not only research but but clinical
settings as well this type of
preservation or fixation is is really
widely utilized by pathologists in
particular it's a really nice way to be
able to get good histology on a on a
specimen the bad part about it is that
it it really compromises your ability to
get molecular information high quality
and reliable molecular information out
of that same tissue the formalin
fixation process really damages nucleic
acids DNA and
RNA there's chemical addicts and
cross-linking that happened between the
nucleic acids themselves and nucleic
acids and protein and it just makes it
very difficult to get reliable and
molecular information out of ffpe
however technologies are advancing not
only in isolating the highest-quality
RNA and DNA you can get out of ffpe but
also technologies like I've been
describing that lend themselves to
interrogating highly degraded and
difficult chemically modified nucleic
acids so I'm currently quantitative
rt-pcr is is is utilized fairly
successfully with ffpe RNA we're now
getting protocols that are working
better with deep RNA sequencing they're
really i and a half will seek is a great
way to look at multiple genes and get
lots of information out of a very small
amount of compromise nucleic acid from
ffpe i'm are validated and recommended
method to isolate RNA front and DNA from
ffpe is using the recover are all total
nucleic acid isolation kit and this has
been published as a preferred method for
extracting total RNA definitely suitable
for quantitative rt-pcr and what we've
done in developing the ampliphi garne
technologies is utilized and test all of
our panels with recover all isolated RNA
from ffpe so this whole workflow has
been fully verified and validated in our
laboratories here
so hopefully I've talked to you about a
couple of different pieces here
isolation methods to deal with ffpe in
particular i focused on ffpe we also
have recommended isolation RNA isolation
procedures from from blood or very few
cells also exosomes we've been working
on those if those are of interest to you
we've talked about highly multiplex
targeted next-generation sequencing and
technologies that allow you to look at
multiple genes at once from very low
amounts of nucleic acid and what I'd
like to bring it together now to address
is is combining these technologies to
really look at fusion gene detection in
clinically relevant sample types so
hoping to get something with better
accuracy and and better ease of use than
current methods like fish faster time to
results and a lower cost so at this
point when we start focusing on how we
utilize these technologies to
interrogate fusion genes I'll I'll pass
it off to my colleague I'm Jeff shaggin
on
good morning everyone for those of you
that are still in the morning section of
your day I'm Jeff shagmon I work closely
with with Kelly and we work together
developing strategies for not only how
do we find the most optimized and best
solutions at a reagent level but also an
analytical level it's not enough just to
walk you to the pond and not allow you
to drink right so we need to have a full
solution and so what I'm going to
concentrate on here is a more about more
about once you have your panel for
looking at multiple fusion genes at one
time how do you analyze those so it's
not enough to just say here's your
sequences and go we wouldn't do that we
put together a full solution and I'm
going to talk more about that now so
before I do that just what you're seeing
now on the screen is a couple of
examples of our some very notable
publications describing the describing
discovered fusion genes and how they can
cause deleterious events and metastatic
cancers and and and cosmetic had
metastatic cancers and also their their
basic characterization whether it be
through looking at fish or quantitative
PCR that kind of thing so this is just
pointing out that we realize there's a
need in the field for getting some
specificity and ease of use as Kelly and
talking a little bit about before so how
do we how do we actually design an assay
to interrogate these fusions in a panel
so what you're seeing here on the screen
to the left is the basic RNA ample seek
workroom we want to do is instead of
just designing primers to a particular
transcript of interest that might be
well annotated in the genome what we'll
do is we'll use a other metadata or
other genomic information that we've
extracted through publications or other
databases which I'll talk about in a
minute and then design primers to each
of each of the the gene partners the
acceptor the donors and acceptor genes
for that transcript
and the idea will be to amplify across
the break point and detect that break
point by sequencing so the the figure on
the right you see the the five-prime
gene the three-prime gene the donor
expedient and the the lines just below
that those gray lines are where we want
to place the primers an amplifier across
the break point there that's shown that
so that green box there with that black
line in the middle that indicates the
break point that break point junction
and so what we want to do is amplify
that section with the essay and then
sequence the amplicon the more the more
sequences we have for that break point
that we can detect the more about the
more confidence we're going to have that
we're actually detecting it and should
mention again I hear that the level of
RNA that this requires is relatively low
even for FFP we're talking about five to
ten nanograms here still so I mentioned
the sources so how do we go about
designing these assays and and where
we're going to get the sequence
information to design them to design the
primers essentially there's a couple of
good places to start in addition to two
publications and being formed by experts
in the field there's a cosmic database
which is a it's a catalog of somatic
mutations in cancer and this this is a
very well annotated database that
doesn't just cover it doesn't Discover
mutations in the form of single variant
single nucleotide variants but also
rearrangements chromosomal
rearrangements and add and making
fusions so we can comb through this
database extract as much information as
possible to do our designs in addition
NCBI has their nucleotide repository of
annotation so in this case we're looking
at EML for alch and this is a commonly
found if it is detected as a fusion and
run cancer and so we can use this
GenBank annotation to go through and
find the information we need to to
synthesize these designs
so a little bullet points about how we
go about doing this so we obtained to
see source sequence as i mentioned from
one of these databases or from from a
paper or from expert opinion we generate
some candidate assays so multiple
multiple primer pairs across a given
locus and we're really leveraging what
we know about I unable to cdna designs
as well as the deck man designs that
have been around for quite a while now
so then we select based on optimal
conditions for these fusions so we want
to be able to guarantee that we can
sequence through a given breakpoint so
we have a size range for these amplicons
that we want to design given what we
know about the average read length
coming off of the ion instrument albeit
a a PGM or a proton instrument so we try
so we try to ensure that we can sequence
through the breakpoint we also want to
be sure that we don't design primers
over known variants so common snips in
the genome single nucleotide variants
that could inhibit how that primer
hybridizes to that trip to that locus
and then we do a final check there's a
QC at the end when we have highly
multiplex panels we look for primer
daimary interactions reciprocal gene
interactions and that's just if you have
a panel where you have a donor gene say
it's a EML for and and then there can't
be don't the donor gene except for gene
are actually both the AML four but
they're involved in different distinct
fusions you don't want to amplify the
wild-type transcript you want to only
amplify the fusion transcript that
contains the breakpoint so we do a check
for that then we also do an internal
priming check to be sure that when we
amplify one amplicon in the panel say
it's just maybe it's a expression
control that happens to be in the panel
with your fusions you don't want to have
another primer design to another a
target use that amplicon as a template
so you run your sequencer on your with
your panel and you have taken it all the
way through to where you have sequence
reads from your eye on PGM sequence are
showing up here on the left in this flow
diagram so what you're looking at here
is the whole analytical flow of how we
analyze fusions and and it's all
contained within a software package
called ion reporter I reporter 4.2 is
there going to be the new release to
come out on jun 27 and will include
support for a for sequent analysis of
fusions with ampliphi so starting up on
the left again here you have your PGM
sequencer at which has reads which had
been can transfer into the eye reporter
software what happens at that point is
those read sequences are mapped back to
a reference which contains your
breakpoint sequences and more likely
more than likely expression control
genes that you wanted to put in your
panel so you have some reads that map
the majority usually math and some that
don't map so looking at the branch of
going going from top to bottom here
looking at the map reads you have your
read that map directly to the breakpoint
sequences and we can tally the number of
reads that map to those breakpoint
sequences to essentially serve as a
proxy for detection of a given fusion
there's also a branch to the top right
after primary mapping for those that
don't match so you have a cadre of reads
that don't map to the reference you
expected there's a few reasons for this
there can be some small degree of target
amplification make causing sequence or
resulting in sequences that you didn't
expect or there could be low quality
sequences what we'll do with these as do
a performer rescue mapping strategy will
take each one of those reads split them
in half and try to look for the acceptor
and donor sequences that we expect it to
be in the panel so going that straight
down from the rescue mapping we want to
confirm those pairs look for them make
sure that the sequence alignment is
actually valid
and perform again this counting step we
tally the number of valid pairs that we
saw occasionally what will happen rarely
actually as when we look for the
accepted donor pairs will find something
we didn't expect so maybe an X and X on
from one one partner that we didn't
expect partnering with in the other side
essentially the two it's an exon exon
pair that we didn't expect to find in a
panel so there is some degree of
detection of non-canonical except there
don't appears that we can pick up with
this process and finally you post
process the data the program post post
process today and normalize the data as
Kelly said that's to the total number of
reads per sample and then you can do a
visualization of it so and that's what
I'll show here on the next couple of
slides so on the slide here this is the
output from the fusion analysis is at
the table of you so you have a locus
this is the chromosomal ruckus that the
type and basically whether it's a fusion
or expression control in this particular
example the genes that are involved with
that particular target the number of
reads that were have been identified and
allocated to that target and whether
it's determined be present or not and
then as you move to the right you have
more annotations in terms of cosmic or
ncbi and what we refer to as the variant
ID which is very similar to the the
genes of the exon cone i just described
and you can dig into some of these links
to to find out more information so the
visualization and normalization view
that i mentioned in that flow diagram so
this is another section of ion reporter
for fusion and analysis and which you
can see here are some tabs at the top
you have your samples workflows and here
this is a fusion analysis heat map you
can see the scale from ranging from 0
that red box there our way to the right
where you have it
the maximum number of counts detected
and this these samples and here in this
particular example we're looking at six
different samples and I want to point
out is that you can mouse over one of
the samples and get more information I
know that might be a little bit hard to
see on your screen but get more
information about the sample that you
just mounting moused over so you know
what you're looking at and then I want
to point out here I did mention some
expression controls and these we
typically add to our fusion panels so we
have a better understanding of how the
overall experiment went there is
positive controls and the the condition
of your RNA so we would expect for these
controls which are not highly expressed
genes their mid to low level expressive
you should expect to see fairly
consistent expression here so the darker
the blue box the higher expression it
looks like in this case for all six
samples you have a consistent expression
across all of them also these samples
that you're looking at here are some
control samples so we knew what to
expect here in this case we are looking
at known fusion positive samples these
are EML for alch fusions that we know to
be detected in a cell line NCSL line
called HC HC 22 HTC 22-28 so these two
these two variants are these two
isoforms of AML for elk are in this
sample we know about that and we do
detect them successfully and you can see
that from the heat map another thing
that we can typically add to these
panels is assays to interrogate the
three prime five prime end of your of
your of genes so if your three prime end
is a 3 prime amplicon is design or five
prime amplicon is designed you can look
at the ratio of the total number of
reads being allocated to each end to see
as at a broad level more of a course
level do we have an indication that a
translocation event occurred where we'd
only see more of a 3 prime end of a gene
and not an out for example a driver gene
like Al Gore Ross or red then we see
with the 5 prime end
so you see here in this example you're
looking at those red boxes in the heat
map the red boxes indicate the five
prime end of the gene and five prime
amplicon measurement and the right next
adjacent to that is a blue box
indicating that we see expression of the
three prime end amplicon so we do see we
could calculate a ratio between the five
prime to three prime end to get some
medication that an alch translocation
has occurred in this particular example
one of the things we did in development
that was very important is we want to
have a better understanding what the
sensitivity of this particular approach
would be with us this technology so we
set up an experiment to where we spiked
in this 22-28 RNA into normal background
of human brain records RNA which does
not have a fusion in it so H 22-28 again
has the e mo for alch a fusion present
in it so what would happen is we titrate
in more and more of the H 2228 RNA into
a background of HBR RNA to end how low
can we go so what you're seeing here is
a heat map again much like the one you
just saw we're across the x-axis at the
top you have all the different fusions
that were contained fusions and
expression control of the following that
were contained within this experiment so
there's a bunch of different EML for out
variants there's some kid fight be read
variants in their CD 64 Ross won some
sex ed 74 Ross one and then across the
y-axis you have all the different
titrations samples so these are six
different libraries of six different
sequencing libraries that went on the
PGM as you move from the bottom of the
y-axis up you're increasing the amount
of sorry you're decreasing the amount of
a 20 to 28 or fusion positive RNA that's
in there so starting at the very bottom
there you have one hundred percent HBR
so all normal RNA there's no detection
of that fusion as indicated from the
heat map but as you move up
you have a hundred percent next up there
you have a hundred percent 22-28 a very
large detect a very high level detection
of a bad fusion this in this case a tml
4x on six and alch x on point then as
you move all the way up that y axis you
get only two ninety nine percent hbr and
one percent 22h 2228 and we see a
detection of that fusion so we're that
gave us some confidence that we could
readily detect the presence of one
percent or even less fusion RNA even in
a background of ninety-nine percent
normal our name this is important
because as you select from a tissue
sample or from an ffpe curl you don't
always get a pure tumor sample you get
some surrounding cells and yours you
also have a very precious amount of RNA
in many cases and you don't have very
much to work with so having this level
of sensitivity is going to be important
going forward for your clinical analysis
so also in the development of this we
worked with some other external
scientists some other customers and we
wanted to find out from real world
samples so they're FFPE samples could we
could we compare our detection method to
what their detection method is and the
state-of-the-art right now is still fish
as kelly pointed out so we were going to
work with the group that had had not
only fish data so what we're calling
known truth to rt-pcr and and and then
so in this table here you've got the
lung sample ffpe 17 / way through 31
there and then moving across those
columns via the fish results are ample
seek approach results and then the
rt-pcr results for each of these samples
and anything you're seeing in green is
where we agree with fish and rt-pcr from
from their original data one thing to
point out to and you might be asking
yourself why why put a bunch of
different fusions in a single panel
well if you in case you're only
interested in measuring a single fusion
or a single variant all i care about is
alcohol might be that you know through
fish that you have an out translocation
or indication of an out translocation we
have no idea what the partner is so
using an amplicon a to measure this you
can actually see with the partners so if
you know it's just an alch translocation
using amp let's see who can find out
it's EML for and not only just EML for
on the other side you can find out which
exon is involved in that translocation
or that fusion transyl so as I as I said
before all of the things that are in
green here for the FFP 17 to 31 or where
we agree but what's interest interesting
here if you go all the way down to the
bottom of your ffpe 30 you see greater
than fifteen percent positive cells for
a fish positive cells for alch and then
by the other technologies know there
were negative by qpcr negative by using
the embassy technology so this could be
an indication that maybe there's a novel
fusion there's a novel fusion that but
we have has yet to be discovered or that
was discovered or detected through fish
or it's a false positive using fish so
as many of you may know fish does have
the propensity to show false positives
and there's some subjectivity there but
one thing we're excited about when it
came to using am place' to do these
measurements is we can really get into
specificity a future detection what type
of fusion were detecting and your level
more of a quantitative level less than a
qualitative level so this is reaching
the end here so this is a summary slide
and just to go through some of what
Kelly's discussed and what I discussed
so we talked about fusion transcript
what they are they are very important
for for understanding
the nature of metastatic disease
especially a tumor types current methods
to do all of this are still very
challenging and the reason we did that
the reason we a reason we started
thinking about this technology way back
when is because we saw this to be a
problem in a way that we can really help
I can get to some more specificity and
sensitivity into into looking at fusions
in their detection Kelly talked about
the the iron ample cigar on a technology
and how we can highly multiplex a multi
multiple genes to a single tube up to
1200 jeans at one time with really low
RNA requirements so so that's really
important like I said if you have very
precious samples we're leveraging the
ambien history of a really working well
and been coming up with the best
possible solutions for RNA isolation so
we have many kids available for lots of
tissues and cells especially ffpe in the
context of today's discussion as well as
blood and then we can we can take all of
that together and we can customize we
can customize the solution to tech
fusion transcripts so we can as I
mentioned we tech down to one percent
tumor RNA also so we we can use less of
your precious RNA so intestinal your
fusions at one time this is very high
resolution so you know all the variants
and the partners the gene partners that
are involved in a fusion transcript the
analysis is essentially pretty much
canned for you now and it you take your
your sequence reads you transfer them
export them to ion reporter you get a
very nice detailed table and
visualization so you can quickly
determine which samples are positive for
for which fusion type and the results
that we've seen so far are definitely
comparable to fish which is currently a
gold standard and rt-pcr detection as
well
so how do we go about how would you in
the audience go about trying to get one
of these panels put together for
yourself so there's there's definitely a
mechanism by which you can do this and
so what we recommend is that you would
put together some accession numbers or
some cosmic IDs of the fusions that
you're interested in or at the very
least some sequences that could be
extracted or derived through a
publication identify some endogenous
control so we can be sure that the RNA
and that the reactions for the whole
system from are working properly at a
technical level and then who do you talk
to so to get this done so you would
contact a field application specialist
or your local sales person to get
involved our white glove program there's
one of these four for DNA already we
have 14 for RNA not just not just
specific to fusions but for other
applications that go beyond the scope of
what we currently offer for RNA embassy
and when we can do is custom design your
fusion transcripts and you will we'll
work with you closely and probably Kelly
will talk talk through to your needs and
address any questions that you have
certainly go to NYC calm to get some
details of more details about the
technology or even if you just want to
play around and design your own a
phantom panel I guess if you even if you
don't even have to order you just want
to see how the system works there's
details about the kits and the reagents
that we sell to get all of this done at
like tech comm just do a search in the
window top right on a life tech a web
page and search for ample seek RNA thank
you very much and with that we'll we'll
put it up the questions which Kelly to
start out with and I appreciate your
time that's the real quick
okay the first question is about
degradation Kelly you touched a bit
about sample degradation and the
question is how can you determine the
quality of the samples being tested it's
very difficult to do let's see that's
very difficult to do with especially
with ffpe RNA generally the way that we
determine RNA quality is by looking at
visualizing the RNA profile on something
like the agilent bioanalyzer instruments
I should use some profiles of that
largely for ffpe RNA it just looks like
a degraded mess so you can use the
bioanalyzer to understand what your
average or mean RNA on sizes that that
will give you some indication of what
you're dealing with our RNA am placing
assays are generally designed to be
around 100 to 150 nucleotides so just
visualizing your RNA and making sure
that you have a reasonable number of
fragments that are at least 100
nucleotides in length would be great but
really what we're focusing on is using
some of these control assays that that
both Jeff and I talked about in a fusion
panel in particular if you have some
nice control gene assays in there it
will tell you your RNA was a high enough
quality to have efficient reverse
transcription occur efficient pcr
amplification occur etc so
those are really the best ways to try to
evaluate your RNA in this type of asset
have those positive control genes make
sure you get good amplification of those
um we're running out of time a little
bit so I'm actually going to just ask
myself the next question I think and it
might save us a little time I see
there's a nice question about can RNA
fusions be multiplex with DNA sequencing
so yes there are DNA amplicon umber
variation hot spots DNA hot spots you
would actually make your libraries
independently on both a DNA and [ __ ]
library and RNA equity library use the
same bar code systems so you have to
just barcode your libraries
intelligently so that you can combine
your RNA library and DNA library for
template prep and sequencing and then
you just with our analysis tools you
would say barcodes 1 through 4 need to
be processed through the DNA hotspot
workflow and barcodes 5 through 8 need
to be processed as an RNA fusion panel
that's all the questions I see let me
pass back to rain a real quick and and
see all right well thank you for all of
your great questions I would like to
thank Kelly and Geoffrey for their
fantastic presentation today and to all
the participants for joining if you'd
like to learn more about I on athletic
technologies and products available
through life technologies please visit
our life technologies booth it can be
accessed from the exhibit hall using the
home button on your screen